Just before we get started with video today,
you've clicked on this one,
you already knows about a place rather than a pass and we're trying something
new.
We're experimenting.
Why not?
This is super interesting.
I promise.
It's like a biography of Chernobyl,
the place and what happened there.
I really think you'll enjoy it and let's get into it.
I exactly.
One 23:00 AM on April the 26,
1986.
The weld suffered its worst ever.
Nuclear disaster outside of the town of preppers in Ukraine,
reacting them before the local nuclear power plants quite literally blew its
top.
It released more nuclear material into the atmosphere than the Hiroshima and
Nagasaki explosions combined.
The resulting cloud of death blanketed half of Europe led to the total
evacuation of parts of north Ukraine and southern Bela reuss and triggered a
process that would end up five years later with the complete collapse of the
Soviet Union.
When we talk about disasters,
there are certainly a scale of disasters in this one.
It rang someone near the top,
but how much do most of us really know about history's worst nuclear accidents?
If you go on wikipedia right now,
it will tell you the total number of deaths due to drug noble is a 31.
The overall impression that you get is that it's a disaster that's noticeable,
but not really on the same league as something like nine slash 11,
but impressions,
they can be misleading for those living in the USSR,
Chernobyl,
it was there 9:11.
It affected workers from each republic in the Soviet Union.
It permanently damaged trust in the government and it left behind a deadly
legacy that still being reckons with to this very day.
In the biographics video today,
we're looking at the story of a town,
the blue up at embark.
It was a chilly February day in 1970 when the first brick of the new city was
laid some 90 kilometers north of Kiev.
Privets was officially under construction as the ninth of the Ussr,
so called atomic towns.
Places built solely for the families of those people working at the nuclear
plants.
In this case that demands the Vladimir Lenin blondes just three kilometers
north.
The plants,
you know today,
it's true noble life in bread,
but it was fun.
I'll be on the standards common in the Soviet Union at that time.
The automatic towns with Moscow,
his pride and joy,
those who lived in them could expect fully stocked shops,
hospitals with actual equipment since apartments that were the envy of people
from Vilnius to have a lot of all stock.
Even by these high standards out there was something else.
Former residents still talk of.
Local forests replete with natural beauty and wax lyrical about visiting the
river.
Beach runs on sweltering summer days,
but from the get go it was a darker side to this new city over at the nuclear
plants or 40 is were quietly installing.
Rbmk reaction is famous back then for that ability to be converted to nuclear
weapon production at the drop of a hat.
This useful ability also made them incredibly unstable like driving a car
without breaks in only a short time.
The reactor to prep it was going to go screaming over a cliff edge,
taking his passengers right along with it.
On the eve of the disaster though,
everything seems to be going well,
just fine.
Officially given city status in 1979,
prep has grown into a booming metropolis,
a 43,000 people with an average age of only 26.
The young population meant no shortage of weddings and celebrations,
and the town had become a hugely desirable posting for Soviet scientists over
the Vladimir Lenin nuclear ponds for as well already up and running with a fifth
one on the way form of private residence later cooled those last days a kind of
paradise.
If that was the case,
it was about to be one that was lost forever.
One of the greatest ironies of the should enable disaster is that it was caused
by of all things safety test.
On the night of April the 25th,
19,
86 engineers,
untrained in nuclear physics,
decided to find out if the newly built react to number four good.
Still operated some emergency water pumps in case of a power failure,
so they disconnected it from all the fail safes,
removed the control rods and shut off the main power source.
There was always a edge that almost immediately ran out of control in a panic.
The engineers tried to reinstate all 200 control rods back into the reactor at
once.
This turned out to be a really bad idea.
The control Rod said graphite tips that facilitated the unstable reactions that
were already taking place no sooner were they in the reactive and it was hit
with the mother of all explosions.
The 1,200 ton cover,
it was blasted into the APP.
Radioactive debris shot a kilometer into the night sky to workers in that
control room.
We'll just killed immediately.
Incredibly.
This survivors of the plans had no idea that just triggered a bonafide
catastrophe there.
Geiger counters what good up to detect,
low amounts of radiation exposure,
the sort of thing you might normally expect from working at a nuclear plant.
When the reactive spewed forth some of the highest radiation levels ever seen,
the geiger counters just stopped working back in prep apps.
The local fire brigade mobilized nearly 30 minutes,
screamed up to the reactor in their trucks with no protective clothing on and
pour water onto the fire.
That was raging,
but the flames,
they wouldn't go out and not only that,
the men complains of a metallic taste on their tongues and the feeling of pins
and needles in that faces by the time they got home.
At the end of that shifts,
a number of these first responders were already showing signs of acute radiation
sickness,
yet still no emergency was declared.
When news reached Moscow at 5:00 AM Soviet leader,
Gorbachev was infamously told that the reaction was so safe,
it could be placed in the middle of Red Square,
had Gorbachev taken them up on that offer would have been a heck of a site.
The ruins of reactor number four,
where at this point buried under 14 tons of highly rubble and burning it 3000
degrees.
It was also spewing radiation over north Ukraine and southern better reuse,
plenty of which was already finding its way to Pripyat.
Is it been a hot night that night and prevents many slept with that window's
open,
unaware the cancer causing particles when are blowing into their bedrooms and
saturating on they're exhausted bodies.
Yet when we woke up,
it wasn't too warranted.
Mass panic to an ordinary day.
Yes,
most of these people were nuclear plants workers and most new something has
happened,
but no one knew the full extent of the disaster.
As radiation fell and invisible deadly clouds.
Children played outside in the streets.
Mothers went shopping and men got ready for work.
The one discordant note was the sudden appearance of mosque soldiers on the city
streets.
They stood in twos or threes,
monitoring the crowds and not answering questions.
It was the first sign the residents of prep outside of the nuclear tsunami that
was about to engulf them all by the evening of April 26 radiation levels in prep
out west 600,000 times the normal,
the excellent documentary,
the basket which neighbor,
which by the way is one of the main sources for the section,
estimated that anyone exposed to those levels would have received a lethal dose
interest for days.
Clearly the Soviet authorities were going to have to react fast.
A tpm on April the 27th with the deadly fire,
still burning three kilometers away,
a thousand school buses were driven into prep and parked on every street
residence were gone outside and told they had two hours to pack their belongings
and prepared to be evacuated.
There's been an accident.
They said,
don't worry,
you'll be away for three days and we'll sort this all out,
and then you can come right back.
I mean,
come on with the Soviet authorities,
we lie to you so that's residents prepared to leave their paradise.
They packed quickly,
taking only what they could carry.
Then all 43,000 when loaded onto the buses and driven away in the vast flat
emptiness of northern Ukraine.
None of these people would ever see that homes again.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
what was going on in Moscow while this nuclear apocalypse was unfolding?
Well,
the answer is nothing.
at least not much.
The credit then did put a scientific delegation together to study the problem,
but aside from that,
Soviet authorities basically sat on my hands like a kid who's faster,
just a party and tried not to let the rest of the big countries see him
blushing.
Unfortunately,
the radioactive fought,
or at least by Chernobyl,
was just like a regular fat in one important respect,
it stank and also in the eggs and then kind of way,
but the stench of radiation which is capable of being picked up by even the most
basic of equipment.
On April the 28th Swedish scientists monitoring their own nuclear plants caught
the first whiff of that silence and very,
very deadly emission with only what we can imagine was a figurative.
They all turns do the other countries and said,
hey guys,
guess what the US is lodges did.
Now will they?
Moscow would try the geopolitical equivalence of whoever smells at Delta for the
next 24 hours.
The jig and it was up on April the 29th.
The Kremlin came clean.
From this point on,
I became a global emergency.
It was around this point that the first responders arrived in Moscow,
is hospital number six,
the one place in the whole of the Soviet Union get up to treat acute radiation,
sickness of the he also farm,
and he would responded that night,
28 would die in agony,
fair skin bund from that boons by an invisible enemy in the aftermath of the
first responders,
deaths and additional a hundred 30,000 people were evacuated from the towns and
villages surrounding prep apps.
Yet even now,
these Soviet authorities response remains woefully lacks in Kiev.
A mayday parade was held with the blessing of the Communist Party despite a
change in wind direction,
meaning radioactive dust was now fooling on the Ukrainian capital like a deadly
reign one week off to the initial blast,
the meltdown.
It was still going on.
The fire itself had been put out with sends,
but the reacts to it continued to burn.
Meanwhile,
dangerous readings were coming in from his phone away is Greece and France.
It was against this worrying backdrop that the International Atomic Energy
Agency made is most worrying announcement default with the reactor melting
downwards through the Pons trenoble.
It was on the brink of a full blown nuclear explosion time,
real quick explainer,
the water,
the first now dead firemen had dumped into the reactor,
had pooled at the bottom with a top of the destroyed reactor,
now plugged with sand to contain the fire.
Any molten radioactive goo that reached the water could trigger a chain
reaction,
which in turn could trigger a nuclear explosion,
and we're talking about something in the range of three megatons yeah,
that's 200 times the size of the bomb that fattened Hiroshima according to the
utterly terrifying online tool,
new comap.
Depending on the way the wind was blowing,
this could have doubts,
not just Minsk,
but also Vilnius,
all the way in Lithuania with catastrophic levels of radiation where the wind's
blowing toward us.
Kiev,
95 kilometers to the south,
it could have turned the Ukrainian capital into a silent tuner.
It was at this point that the liquidators arrived in the last years of the USSR.
The liquidators were the equivalent of nine slash 11 first responders,
the men and women who were marched into the jaws of death determined to do that
duty.
They comprised army reservists,
firemen,
nurses,
police officers,
miners and pilots,
plus the scientists and workers who accompanied them.
They came from every single one of the Soviet republics,
from Estonia to Georgia,
from Kazakhstan to as Pakistan old,
old,
half a million of them converged on Chernobyl during the dark days of mid 1986.
Very few of them escaped on Scott.
To read this story is to read a tale of heroism and suffering,
not seen since the siege of Stalin Grad.
There are the 600 pilots who flew over the burning reactive,
dropping lead on it to plug the broken top.
Latest suffered myriad health problems.
There are 125 five and sent beneath the meltdowns and drain the water out and
stop the second explosion,
most of whom got sick and then there are the 10,000 miners who came from Russia
to create a concrete chamber beneath the reactor to stop it poisoning the
groundwater.
Two thousand 500 of which would die before the age of 40 that were then ordered
to clear radioactive debris from the roof of the power plants were radiation
levels were so high they have to work in 40 seconds.
Shifts or risk receiving a fatal dose.
Miners were forced to dig in 24 hours shifts without any protective clothing.
Then there are all the stories of the cleanup decontamination at the sign
itself.
The countryside surrounding Pripyat was so contaminated.
Entire forest tent to be bulldozed,
buried villages were scrubbed from tip to toe,
perhaps most shockingly special squads were given guns and sent out into the
countryside to shoot all the dogs and cats less.
They're radioactive now prove a danger to humans all told.
It was one of the biggest clean operations in human history,
rivaling even deepwater horizon.
It lasted six months,
whereupon a 30 mile exclusion zone was established around prep apps and it
remains there to this very day.
The final capstone was the sarcophagus.
This was a concrete Bam off.
It was placed over the reactor at the very end of 1986,
just as the first snows began to fall.
It seals reacts number four off from the outside world completely ensuring that
it would remain safe at least for a time you see the sarcophagus.
It was built in a hurry and there was designed to only last 30 years.
This wasn't seen as a problem is when 2016 finally rolled around.
The Soviet authorities would clearly still be in charge and Ukraine and that'd
be able to replace it with another one.
I mean,
it's not like the entire Ussr always gonna compete.
You collapsed in the next half decade or so,
right
on November the ninth,
19,
89.
The world watched in horror as ordinary Germans toppled great chunks of the
Berlin Wall.
Well,
God swatched on it was the start of the complete collapse of communism in
Eastern Europe and the final dissolution of the USSR in Ukraine,
mass protests against Moscow didn't break out until 1991,
but when they did,
they did so under trend nobles,
deadly cloud in Kiev,
protesters were photographed in gas masks.
And protective clothing waving signs referencing the disaster at a political
level.
The shutting out of Ukrainians from a disaster in their own backyard had immense
consequences,
the most immediate of which was key ever declaring independence on August 24th
that year,
but the fallout from Chernobyl had effects fall beyond Ukraine.
The Economist has argued that the huge economic hits the USSR took from the
disaster directly lead to its collapse,
but on the fringes of the Chernobyl exclusion zone,
former residents of prep had watched these events with undoubtedly mixed
feelings while their homes had been lost,
the authorities that built them a new city to recreate that paradise.
Many of them still worked at the old power powerplan's.
Remarkably,
the three other reactors had been restarted by the end of 1986.
Apparently,
danger be damned yet new cities can't make up for the toll.
Trenoble took on its liquidators across the USSR.
Hospitals had spent the last five years flooded with those who worked in the
zone today.
It's estimated that around a third of the surviving liquidators are disabled in
some way in Bela Reuss,
which got more radiation than Ukraine.
One study estimated that as many as 20 percent of the adolescent population
suffered birth defects related to the accident,
as for the number of excess cancer deaths Chernobyl caused,
we simply don't know the World Health Organization estimated on the 20th
anniversary that it was around 4,000,
but estimates vary wildly.
One of you report,
but the number closer to $60,000,
whatever the truth,
the aftermath of Chernobyl has been a source of anger in Ukraine and better
batteries ever since when the plants,
other reactors were finally shut down and following international pressure in
2001 few lamented that passing the drama when it wasn't over in the late 19
nineties,
it became clear that Ukraine was never going to be capable of rebuilding the
sarcophagus.
When it finally failed,
it was at this point that it became abundantly clear that the sarcophagus was
never going to make us until 2016,
despite being built to last 30 years.
The Soviet sarcophagus was already on the brink of collapse.
The next 10 years alone were spent shoring up the old structure to prevent
another catastrophe.
Then in the mid two thousands and new song called Fergus had to be built that
would completely contained the old one at a staggering 35,000 tons.
The new sarcophagus,
it was a miracle of engineering,
builds 300 meters away from react to number four to limit radiation exposure.
It took 10 years to assemble.
It then had to be rolled over the old sarcophagus and completely sealed.
It was taller than the statue of liberty and bigger than an Olympic stadium when
it was finally sealed in November of 2016,
and it cost one point $5,000,000,000.
This one though,
it's expected to last the next one,
hundred years.
During that time,
robots inside.
We'll deconstruct the old sarcophagus before finally dismantling and making the
reactor itself safe.
When the new sarcophagus finally reaches his end in 2116,
it's hoped humanity,
we need to build an even bigger one today.
The glistening new structure,
it looks over a landscape that's very different from the one reacted.
Number four,
changed forever.
In 1986,
the x paradise of prep that is no longer just empty this crumbling away beneath
and on sort of nature,
the ones team forest,
so now so devoid of people that the exclusion zone has become an accidental
wildlife reserve.
Teaming with wolves,
bears,
beavers,
and links,
not the people that have completely vanished though just a few short years ago,
the Ukrainian government agreed to let a small number of Chernobyl evacuees back
in around $200.
Now,
if within the zone itself,
dicing with death on a daily basis,
you can even go to visit them tonight.
We'll receives tens of thousands of tourists a year drawn by the allure of
Ukraine's,
very own pompei and I actually went to did this last year and it's well worth
doing as for the disaster itself.
Well,
thankfully it remains the worst nuclear accidents on record that as the
Fukushima meltdown in 2011 was,
it didn't even come close to 1986 eruption.
Hopefully neither accident will ever be exceeded.
Now,
normally this is the point where we wrap up a biography and say a few pithy
things and just that those credits roll,
but Chernobyl story when it's still far from Ovid,
it's estimated that the zone will remain uninhabitable for humans for another
24,000 years,
a stretch of time that's almost beyond comprehension.
It was only four and a half thousand years ago that the pyramids were first
built in Egypt.
Try to imagine for a moment just how different life was back then,
how impossible it would have been for your average slave to close his eyes and
imagine our orwell's to imagine spaceflight penicillin,
the outs now,
multiply that feeling by a factor of six.
You'd have some idea of the scale of time left until Chernobyl's affects.
Stop being felt.
I'll story today.
It might be over,
but the tale of Chernobyl is only just getting started,
so I hope you found this video interesting and there's a little bit different to
our normal stuff,
but we thought we'd try a biography of a place just for a change of pace.
I found this one personally super interesting and if you did like it,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
Let us know in the comments what you think of doing this sort of video every now
and again would love to hear from you and as always,
thank you for watching.